let's go next to our caller from the
eight five six area code who's calling
today from eight five six all right
David I'm Erin from New Jersey and I
thank you for taking my call
my pleasure I wanted to follow up on I
guess the theme of last week's calls
which was this kind of division among
the list now um we agree that we need to
really stop all this infighting among
the Democratic Party but my question is
where does that start because to be
honest with you I'm a kind of a die-hard
Joe Biden fan like if Bernie like takes
the nomination I mean like that's great
because like I'm not denying that he has
a good chance of winning against Trump
but like I'm gonna be looking for him to
reach out to like disaffected Hillary
Clinton voters and like Joe Biden fans
like myself and like kind of start that
process so we're getting better I mean
if Joe Biden won the nomination would
you be likewise looking to him to reach
out to people who say I am way more
progressive than Joe Biden and I don't
know why I should vote for him like
would you like wise expect that of Biden
absolutely anyway okay so we want to be
consistent on that now what makes you a
die-hard Joe Biden fan and what's
interesting to me about that is just
that Joe Biden it's hard for me to
imagine feeling so strongly about Joe
Biden because he's just very very Center
so it's like it's hard for me to get
motivated around centrism so like what
makes you such a die-hard Biden guy well
I feel like they're like there's this
connection between Biden Bernie and
Trump okay in that like finding Bernie
are are trumps in that they have this
character it like they have this
personality that just makes you want to
like them like that's well uh well a lot
of white people like from like and
that's why I kind of like them too even
though I vote for Hillary of course but
I was like I will find from entertaining
and I find Joe Biden entertaining okay
but hold on a second so my you I'm just
trying to sort untangle all this you you
liked Trump in the same way that you
like Bernie and Biden
um not in the same way that I like
bernie i think bernie is better on
policy but I know that people are
attached to Bernie in that way uh-huh
okay but yeah I think that your
lightning you liked Trump but you voted
Hillary and you like Bernie but you're a
Biden supporter and is what about on
policy like what Biden policies do you
like well that's the thing it's not
really about policy for me even though I
do appreciate good policies but what's
more important to me is like just being
an entertaining person so for you and
why you have that line of entertainment
is an important thing in terms of who
you want to be the president of the
United States yeah just being a likable
person I feel like that's incredibly
important like Joe Biden's the line of
malarkey I think that play is really big
for me where are you on health care
policy what health care policy would you
like oh well I'm a bit of a moderate I
think that keeping the ACA would be
great although if you want to do more
than that that's fine but it's all about
personality with me well and I want to
just clarify it I don't really I don't
like Trump but to interchange me I hate
his policies I hate the guy well you
know Aaron I'm worried the country from
what your to what you're what you're
telling me is really concerning to me
I'm not gonna lie so just to get back to
the question though what like does the
healing start with the candidate or with
the voters I think it's both I think
it's both simultaneously you got a we
need we need disagreement within the
Democratic primary that is not the type
of disagreement that then ends up
helping Trump later on it's a gray area
so I know that there were people
emailing me about this David how can you
on the same at the same time say that
the left has to be careful about
infighting but criticized Democratic
candidates aren't you doing the thing I
think you got to find a balance and we
need to say all of these people would be
better than Trump during the primary
let's fight out let's fight it out for
the candidate whose policy matches ours
but then when it gets to the general
election we've got to do the right thing
Erin I'm gonna let you go I'm quite
concerned about how important the
entertainment factor is to you and I
worry that it does not bode well for the
country but I really appreciate you
sharing your thoughts with me
all right very good I'm gonna take a
quick break if you're holding don't hang
up we will go back to the phones right
after this don't hang up if you're
holding